spider-man was always one of my favorite
superheroes when I was a kid and the
reason for that was definitely the way
that he moved
spider-man moved unlike any other
superhero or any other character from
film or TV really he's always landing in
these cool poses with his legs stretched
out he's crawling along the ceiling like
some kind of creepy alien and in
movement he's agile he's fast he's
preternatural thanks to his spider sense
and it's just that she unique skill set
and of course extremely watchable last
time I forged spider-man of course the
question that I'm interested in is
whether we can move like lessons
specifically what training we should do
what training we should add to our
routines in order to become that add
dial and that fluid so this new series
I'll be looking at moves and concepts
you can add to your training to help you
move a little bit more like Peter Parker
or this video we'll be looking at
contralateral training and training each
side of your body independently and
future I'll be looking at mobility and
propriety section and animal moves if
that all sounds cool let's go
the bilateral deficit tells us that
we're capable of exerting more strength
from a single arm when we use that arm
alone rather than in conjunction with
another arm that tells us for instance
that in theory if we perform single
armed uni lateral dumbbell curls we'll
be able to exert more strength than if
we perform barbell curls the reason for
this isn't fully understood but it's
generally thought to be to do with the
neural drive with the mind muscle
connection and our central nervous
system in other words it takes double
the effort to use both arms and
therefore you see a slight loss in your
strength that means that if you perform
unilateral dumbbell curls instead of
barbell curls you should be able to lift
more weight and therefore see more
growth this can also help to improve
symmetry somewhat ironically because of
course you can't use your other limb to
help and there's another benefit to
training this way as well and that's
that when you train one limb actually
has a knock-on effect on the other limb
to the tune of about 50% so if you only
trained bicep curls with your right arm
your left arm would enjoy 50% of those
same strength gains again this is
thought to have to do with the mind
muscle connection you're actually
strengthening the neural Maps even
though the muscle on that side wouldn't
actually be growing so you become more
efficient in that movement this might
have to do with the fact that we often
use our arms together and therefore the
neural maps are somewhat linked in our
brains
remember neurons that fire together wire
together that means that when you use
your right arm your left arm is also
somewhat lighting up and you're
strengthening those neural connections
that means that if you train using
unilateral exercises so perform a number
of curls on your right arm then a number
of curls on your left arm you'd actually
potentially be essentially doing more
volume at least as far as your central
nervous system was concerned this is
what's known as the contralateral
strength training effect or sometimes
across education and this might also
provide an interesting option for
training whilst you're injured at least
if you train the healthy limb that will
prevent some loss of strength in the
injured limb and it's a fantastic way to
increase your athleticism your
proprioceptive said the right and left
limbs are linked in the brain likely due
to the amount of tasks we partake in
that involve both being used at the same
time for an efficiency standpoint it
makes a ton of sense for the body to
cheat for the brain to cheat
and only send one set of instructions if
both limbs move at the same time or in
an opposing manner
you only have to think about moving one
instead of thinking about moving to
opposition being the word we use to
describe movements where the limb moves
in the opposite way for instance doing a
crawl or when we're walking even so what
if instead of using your arms either
together or on their own you train them
using slightly different movements well
this is what's known as contralateral
training sometimes and guess what
training a right arm can even strengthen
your left leg and vice versa
all your limbs are somewhat linked in
your neural map you might have heard
that the left side of the brain controls
the right side of the body and the right
side of the brain controls the left this
isn't 100% true sometimes the same side
of the brain will control the same side
of the body and it's even possible for
that control to migrate from one side of
the brain to the other in rare
circumstances for the most part this X
shaped image is accurate anatomically
the movement of the right shoulder is
also linked to the movement of the left
hip and vice versa and this is why we
walk the way we do swimming our arms in
an opposing manner so when you train in
this way using crawls we're using walks
you're actually strengthening these
connections and thereby improving some
of your explosiveness your agility and
your core strength you might even be
thickening the bundle of nerves that run
from the left of the right hemisphere in
the brain called the corpus callosum
like ambidexterity training but with
weights this movement also forces us to
use our obliques to resist torque as do
any movements where we're using
different amounts of resistance on the
left and the right sides this helps us
to stabilize ourselves which makes us
much more agile much more athletic and
also impossible to push over and
whenever you train using offset loads or
alternating movements like this on the
left and right side you're also
increasing your proprioception with
kinesthetic awareness because you're now
concentrating on moving both sides of
the body separately there are plenty of
different ways you can incorporate
contralateral training into your current
training one of those like I say is
crawls to spider-man crawls or bear
crawls are you moving close to the
ground and holding yourself in that low
position it's also just grateful sorts
of other things it's a great PEC workout
because it's got that isometric hold and
it's actually fairly Turing so it can
even be useful as a kind of finish it
one-armed one-legged push up using
opposite sides is another fantastic
demonstration and test of your core
strength as well as your contralateral
strength and it's a great way to build
that up and farmers walks especially
ones where you're more waiters on one
side such as the suitcase carry are
another great option
finally exercise we're performing
slightly different movements on each
side or at the top and the bottom of the
body will also tax your brain your
central nervous system that little bit
more things like hanging from a pull-up
bar and performing curls a cool tricks
to try and work towards of course some
exercises like the Turkish getup
naturally involve different movements
from the different limbs all at the same
time wanna see how difficult it is to
concentrate on movement from the two
sides of your body then try patting your
tummy and rubbing your head nope rubbing
your tummy and patting your head and
you'll see what I mean
so I hope you found it useful
interesting guys if you did then thanks
a ton for watching please subscribe for
more like this share it around that
helps me out immensely and comment down
below and let me know what contralateral
exercises you use or any I've missed I'd
love to hear your thoughts thanks so
much for watching this and I'll see you
next time bye for now
yep I am a grown man I'm somebody's dead